[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attends mais je suis pas B du tout
alors devant toi
mais dans le M
[Applaudissements]
pas vous allez voir c'est un abri donc a
on a la falaise qui est juste au-dessus
ils ont mis depuis un toit pour protéger
les les gens qui venaient là après
histoire il s'abritaent sous la falaise
naturelle là ce qui ce qui rend le site
précieux et important enfin je il est
connu par tous les préhistoriens
européens voilà la grande riv voir c'est
un site de référence tu as pratiquement
10000 ans de présence humaine qui sont
catalogués sur sur 6 ou 7 m d'épaisseur
moi au son là j'entends des tas de trucs
des tas de trucs le l'aspirateur tu veux
dire
bah ouais
ouais ça va être un peu un peu bruyant
parce que il y a une la méthodologie de
fouille elle est très spécial et
notamment tu verras pas une pioche tu
verras pas un piochon ça nexiste pas et
dès qui s'agit d'enlever c'est
l'aspirateur tu as pas de pelle ni de
balayette ni de voilà tu récupères le
contenu de l'aspirateur et chaque
aspirateur fait un saut chaque saut est
amisé parce que quand tu retrouves
quelque chose dans ton tamis il faut que
tu puisses dire où est-ce qu'il était
sur le site donc la contrepartie de ça
c'est vrai c'est que toute la journée tu
as des moteurs d'aspirateur qui tournent
tu as un groupe électrogène qui est
là-haut pour alimenter tout ça donc tu
as le ronronnement du groupe électrogène
qui alimente en électricité tu vas voir
il un compteur électrique qui est dans
la falaise calcaire carrément on vient
se brancher dessus en plus tout est
suspendu au dessus du sol avec des
échafaudages et des planches parce qu'il
faut que rien ne touche donc c'est une
espèce de de structure qui qui porte
dans la
falaise il faut que tout le monde soit
suspendu au-dessus du niveau
archéologique c'est assezmouvant même
temps par que c'est la fin d'une fouille
qui a commencé depuis les années 80 et
là voilà 2022 normalement ce sera
terminé et donc c'est un site qui est
placé sur une voie de circulation très
importante aujourd'hui mais aussi
pendant toute la préhistoire et toute ce
qu'on appelle la préhistoire récente
c'estàdire depuis la dernière glaciation
depuis 14000 12000 avant notre ère
jusqu'à aujourd'hui voie de circulation
donc entre la plaine de lis
est juste en dessous là où est Grenoble
et les au plateau du verrecor où
aujourd'hui on dénombre plus d'une
centaine de sites préhistoriqu
mésoliique néolithique donc c'est
vraiment une grande voie de passage on
est sur le point le plus septentrional
du massif et c'est l'un des principaux
accès sur les plateaux du vercor
mésolitique
9200 5800 avant jus ici c'est un abri
sous roche donc qui est orienté au sud
donc ça aussi ça a toute son importance
on a une couverture naturelle de l'abri
qui couvre environ 4 m car au sol et
tout ce qui est sous l'abri c'est
niveaux qui sont plutôt bien conservés
don quand on parle d'occupation sous
l'abri ça veut pas dire qu' avait pas en
amont mais on les a pas aujourd'hui par
qu'elles ont été décidé voyez de
gigantesque trou qui est juste devant
vous là entre la route et le site qui
est assez particulier souvent les gens
quand ils viennent
ici ils sont venus s'installer là il y a
un trou c'est quand même pas très pas
très sympa en fait ce ce trou c'est une
exploitation en carrière pour les Jeux
Olympiques de 68 de 1968 pour les jeux
olymiques de grenuble jeux olympique
d'hiver il y a eu des épreuves de ski de
so à ski notamment sur le plateau ils
ont refait la route de Villard qui de
d'accès au au plateau et donc ils ont
exploité tout cet espace sans savoir
qu'il y avait un site archéologique bien
évidemment c'est une photo d'avant 1968
justement ici vous avez la route on
distingue la route à flan
à Villard vous avez cette grande cette
grande Lenti cette grandes falaise de
calcaire Sénonien qui est ici et le site
de la grande Rivoire se
trouve il est là il est il est ici donc
c'est c'est une photo qui permet de vous
montrer que outre le fait que la
végétation a quand même radicalement
changé en 60 ans le l'environnement la
morphologie du terrain la géographie a
aussi radicale vraiment changé vous
voyez que l'accès au Furon au lit de la
rivière bah finalement on avait une
espèce de pente douce et que c'était
plutôt plutôt favorable en tout cas au
déplacement de population et puis à des
occupations humaines en tout cas dans
cette abri donc le site ensuite a été
laissé à l'abandon comme ça et en 1986
il y a un pompier grenaublois qui
s'appelle Jacques marin lui était bon
c'était un passionné un amateur
d'archéologie passionné donc il faisait
des prospections dans le coin et puis
dans dans les dans les débl qui sont
sous le sous le site il a trouvé de la
faune des restes de des fragments de
faune animal du sil ex
des des tessons de céramique peut-être
même une hache polie il a il a averti
les autorités compétentes et notamment
Régis picav qui travaillait travaillit
en TR dans le coin et qui était
archéologue et donc lui est intervenu
entre 1986 et
1994 donc à la base il sont vraiment
partis sous le sous la forme de campagne
de sauvetage c'est un site dont le les
dépôts de pente étaient tellement
entamés qu'il y avait un effondrement
constant des des niveaux archéologiques
et donc le site est en train de se
détruire progressivement vous voyez
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs la pente qu'on a
qui est tellement importante tout est
voué à l'effondrement et à la perte de
toutes ces données qui sont qui sont
riches et qui sont vraiment uniques
surtout pour
le pour la période pour la
région
microlit cétait pas fait
exprès bon quand même à chaque fois
super bon ouais
regarde typiquement les pointes de
flèches que l'on retrouve dans nos
niveaux un petit triangle en donc c'est
fait pour être c'est en manché de
matière latérale sur une e de flèche ce
qu'on sait globalement des premières
études un peu préliminaires c'est que le
silex provient tuas çaent du ball de
lance plus au sud tu as le Diwa ouais on
a du de bonne qualité vacieux
probablement aussi tout ce qui est
pointe de flèche et ouillage de ce type
tu en as jamais en silex local c'est que
du c'est que du silex avec un grain très
fin la bonne matière
ou je vais vous donner ces trois
flèches hop
et je vous me laisser me les mettre dans
l'ordre
chronologique C je sais pas du tout à
quoi sert donc je capable de
[Applaudissements]
dire pour interrogation sur les deuxot
ouis un pe c'est laquelle la plus
ancienne pour vous c ok bon ça c'est la
plus ancienne ok bon ça ça va au milieu
et ça c'est la plus récente voilà ici on
a ce qu'on appelle une pointe axiale on
retrouve dans le
jargon du du pour le pour le mésolitique
ceon appelle une pointe de sauetir donc
c'est un élément éément axial et ici en
barbelure ce sont ce qu'on appelle des
triangles scalaines ou des éléments de
barbelure on pe utiliser différents
termes ce qui permet d'avoir sur une
même Ampe de flèche vous avez un élément
perçant un élément découpant et un
élément de rétension ce qui va faire que
ça va rester planté fiché en tout cas
dans la dans la peau de l'animal ENF en
tout cas dans la dans le corps de
l'animal voilà pour le premier
mésolitique c'est une période qui dure
presque 2500 ans avec différentes phases
évolutives et grâce à ces pointes de
flèches qui sont pour nous nos marqueurs
chronoculturels c'est avec ça qu'on peut
dater nos couches de manière relative on
vient compléter tout ça avec des
datations radiocarbone ce qui permet
d'avoir une précision un petit peu plus
une précision plus scientifique en tout
cas des datations
absolu
ça c'est le ce qu'on appelle le second
c'est une pointe de flèche du second
mésolitique alors c'est une V de
population c'est probablement une vague
migratoire qui arrive d'Afrique du Nord
là les plus vieilles dates qu'on est
pour le second mésoitique c'est 6400
avant jésuschist à peu près et donc ce
sont encore des chasseurs cuilleurs ce
sont encore des des populations de de
chasseurs mais qui arrivve avec une
toute nouvelle technologie ce qu'on
appelle des
trapèzes donc c'est des c'est des blocs
qui sont un peu plus gros et ils vont
venir débiter des lamelles un peu plus
allongées beaucoup plus régulières qui
leur permet d'avoir une flèche composite
donc au lieu d'avoir plein de petits
éléments cette fois-ci ils vont avoir
sur une seule même pointe plus lourde un
élément perçant un élément découp
coupant et une rétention donc le
principe est exactement le même ensuite
on a le Néolithique et eux ils vont
arriver avec des pointes de flèchees un
peu bizarre comme ça ce qu'on appelle
des flèches tranchante d'un point de vue
technologique c'est exactement la même
chose dans le débitage
que pour le second mésolitique c'est
vraiment en tout point similaire la
seule différence va être dans
l'emmanchement de ces pièces et la
provision manchement la plus plausible
serait comme ça en flèche tranchante
alors en expérimentation ça a été ça a
été fait ça marche très bien
en en percussion en tout cas directe ça
se plante pas vraiment ça a plutôt
tendance à rebondir par contre si ça
arrive de manière
tangentiel ça fait des PL qui sont moins
profondes qu'une qu'une flèche qu'un
impact de flèche direct par contre ça va
venir l'cérer et découper l'animal sur
une une bonne partie ça va venir
ricocher en fait sur l'animal et ça va
faire des PL qui sont assez quand même
profonde mais beaucoup plus longue et
l'anivale va probablement saigner donc
mourir beaucoup plus rapidement il y a
aussi tout l'aspect qu'on connaî pas et
c'est là où l'etno peut nous servir
c'est sur bah est-ce qu'il utilisent
aussi des poisons qui mettait aussi sur
ces
pièces d'un point de vue technologique
c'est vraiment pareil et on sait pas
vraiment qui euh qui des mésolithiques à
culturé néolithique ou inversement ou
est-ce qu'il y a eu plutôt échange
est-ce qu'il y a eu mélange de
traditions on peut imaginer un milliard
de trucs mais c'est intéressant c'est
chouette vous avez vu ce matin il y a
les deux secteurs enfin le secteur de
fouille et le secteur de
tamisage comme les vestices sont très
fragmenté petit et cetera il y a à peu
près plus de la moitié qu'on retrouve
ici donc ça fait partie quand même de la
fouille c'est quand même important c'est
pas c'est pas une punition le Tami on
prend le Tami de 18 ou 12 et un Tami
4 donc on a une petite colonne de Tami
comme ça on prend un
saut on vient là sur le
tamillon
ensuite comme
ça ensuite on repasse à la flotte
ici on récupère les charbons pour les
études en
TR ça votre il scoule prenez une petite
boîte de peloche photo en essayant de
pas trop les écraser récupérer là aussi
un maximum de
charbon
GR2 2022 un petit point LGM donc limon
gris
moyen limon
brun un peu foncé comm par descendre les
caillou en regardant regardez ceux qui
sont un peu
étranges vigilant
descendez
on a un petit fragment d'éclat le silex
vous mettez dans la petite
passoire encore
ou vous fait deux fois là j'ai encore
loupé plein de truc
s j'étais passé à côté jeavais pas fait
deux fois
là on va faire la maille de la petite
maille c'est là qu'on peut avoir les
petits microlites comme ça là il faut
être un peu plus
vigilant ça peut être très long faire
attention aux toutes petites
esquis donc au début vous allez dire ou
là là faut pas paniquer hein on check le
moindre petit truc petit bout d'os
Peet éclat
là et l'éclat de silex il aura toujours
une face supérieure et une face
inférieure la face inférieure elle sera
lisse et la face supérieure c'est un
petit peu et la face supérieur il y aura
des traces des enlèvements précédents
alors le silex de la falaise il est
orange ou rosé cel ouis il est pas du
tout de la falaise là il y a aucun doute
celui-là il est pas venu tout seul ouais
donc on le garde on se dit pas il est
taillé pas taillé ça c'est pas un
problèmeel et là magnifique c'est un
micro alors il est très
beau c'est une armature tu
vois donc là on a le dos de l'armature
qui a été retouché on a la aussi les
petites retouches donc il va peut-être
servir de barbelure donc si tu regardes
à la
loupe ça vous la laisserez aussi vous
pouvez la regarder pas la
PA tu
regardes tuas les
enlèvements et là le bord tu vas voir
des petites des petites écailles ah
oui tu vas voir ce genre de truc là la
troncature troncature c'est quand c'est
une des
extrémités de l'éclat qui est retouché
donc là tu auras ça là on aura un bord
un peu solide et puis là il pourra être
légèrement
égrisé et des microlites comme ça vous
en trouver beaucoup tous les
jours là dans dans ces niveaux là ouis
on en
a des fois on en a plus d'une dizaine
par
jour ou c'est c'est vraiment les niveaux
ils sont super
riches
pardon mais le sol là c'est uniquement
de la poussière en fait de fouille ouais
et alors encore mieux les refus de tamis
une fois qu'on a fini de le trier on
jette là et ça fait un CNE des bouli
artificiel il y a 20 ans de ta mise à
[Musique]
jour si on t' miseit pas ici mais on
passera côté de 90 % du matériel on
pourrait dire B la fouille ça suffit on
va pas s'embêter à tout alors contamise
absolument tout mais on perdrait un
nombre incalculable de d'objets de
matériel d'information je pense que le
premier risque c'est de pas voir ce que
tu fais c'est d'où l'intérêt d'avoir des
gens qui sont le responsable souvent il
se tient toujours tu dis mais il fouille
pas l'archéologue qu'est-ce qu'il fait
bah non en fait il il est toujours en
train de se poser la question de merde
qu'est-ce que c'est que ce truccl là
est-ce que c'est pas en rapport avec
autre chose est-ce qu'on est pas en
train de faire une connerie par est-ce
que je descends trop est-ce qu'on
s'arrête là pour faire une photo attends
voir enfin tu vois c'est parce que après
une fois que c'est enlevé c'est détruit
donc tu le risque permanence à l'esprit
personne fait ça tout seul ça travaille
d'équipe l'archéologie ouais ouis non
l'archéologue seul qui a toutes ses
pièces chez lui et qui travaille dans
son bureau et qui faut fort puis qui
écrit un super bouquin et Machin non
c'est maintenant c'est vraiment c'est
plus un travail d'équipe de toute façon
sans spécialiste on peut pas tout savoir
là on gère le chantier on gère la
méthodo on essaie d'avoir des données
les plus plus précise possible et puis
après on
dispatch tu peux pas étudier et les
pollenes et le silex et les ossements
des animaux
et à Lyon on pose une question par
exemple sur sur tel caillou et quelqu'un
disait mais demander demander à Jérôme
c'est lui qui gère c'est le spécialiste
des cailloux
Cu dans la
préparation nouveau chantier de fouille
est-ce que ça démarre par des réunions
ou ou ou oui oui oui oui tu tu discutes
de la méthod alors nous on a la chance
parce que tout était en place on a juste
reprendre tu si je me trompe mais tu
sentais pas de le faire vraiment tout
seul on s dit on va faire ça on va faire
c'est lui qui a l'autorisation de
fouillei responsable nous de on complète
bien gratt un peu mais doucement tu
descends pas au niveau du petit trou là
que le caillou a fait et puis après il y
aura
ça mais autrement c'est pas
maland lesé son arrivésé à ce niveau non
c'était beaucoup plus haut quand les
archéologues sont arrivés ça c'est le
niveau de sol on marchait là on marchait
là sur les petits points
rouges jusque
là-bas donc depuis 2003 2000 il pouvait
enlever jusqu'à 50 cm voir plus de
ségiments par année c'est beaucoup ça
c'est énorme on se rend pas compte non
on se rend pas compte nous on enlève si
on arrive à enlever 20 cm par c'est bien
cmè on a fait 25 je crois et 25 par ça
représent combien deoccupation combien
de
temps 500 ans 500 an 25
[Applaudissements]
cm un site qui une histoire sédimentaire
vraiment vraiment importante et pieric
en 2000 c'est un suisse de l'Université
de Genève qui travaille sur les péries
néolithiques est intervenu pendant 18
ans donc entre 2000 et 2017 et grâce à
lui et grâce à Régis SP ils ont pu
mettre en évidence une occupation quasi
continue sur 10 millénaire sur environ 6
m de puissance stratigraphique depuis
les périodes historiques galloromain
jusqu'au premier mésolitique c'estàd
quasiment 10 millénaires d'occupation
entre 9000 avant notrere
et
moi il y a 10 ans c'était le niveau de
bergerie on avait du noir du blanc du
noir du blanc un joli millefeuille
couche de fumier cramé super noir avec
des petits morceaux de silex et cetera
et qui était voilà c'est ça les niveaux
de bergeux c'est tous ces sédiments très
organiques que vous voyez là c'est le
niveau de parquage de de caprinet ici on
a la chance d'avoir à la fois un abri et
ces deux grandes diaclases ces deux
grandes failles qui sont venus apporter
du sédiment de de manière régulière et
constante ce qui fait que quand il y a
eu occupation humaine et ben les niveaux
archéologiques se sont recouverts très
rapidement le fait que ce soit recouvert
rapidement ça permet une bonne
conservation des niveaux aujourd'hui on
a la chance de fouiller des niveaux qui
sont bien conservés et très probablement
je reste quand même sur probablement en
[Musique]
place
en gros qu'est-ce qui t're vers la
préhistoire plutôt qu'une autre
période une bonne question ce qui
m'attire c'est que 99 % de la vie
l'homme
moderne se passeant la
prist tu vois pendant 99 % de
notre notre existence pour l'instant on
a été chasseur cuilleur et on a eu un
rapport semble-t-il à l'environnement
différent que CELI qu'on a maintenant
c'est c'est c'est des trucs de gamin
après moi depuis tout petit he tu sais
je joue avec des bâtons des cailloux ça
fonctionne à l'imaginaire aussi exement
complètement oua ouaou VO du coup à la
grand roir les cailloux voilà tu pas
ENIT les cailloux en plus c'est vraiment
des tout petits cailloux et tu dis tu
dis punaise les mecs il font des tout
petits cailloux et ils arrivent quand
même à à manger à vivre correctement
parce queon les imagine toujours tu sais
qu' qui survivent qu' sont là à crever
la dalle à essayer de de chasser le
moindre bestiole pour manger j'ai pas
l'impression que c'était ça parce que
quand on retrouve les osems là on a
quand même pas mal d'ossem de gros
animaux un dessert et cetera si tu tues
un sert pour 10 ça tu pourend un petit
moment ouais en sachant qu'il y a pas
que les ser il y a tous les petits
animaux les lapins les oiseaux les
oiseaux tout ce qui est rongeur et
cetera plus
tout ce qui se cueille
PL ça ça pouvit se passer relativement
bien intéressant c'est de voir comment
pouz faire avec de notre point de vue
pas grandchose-ce quez de quelle espèce
il
s'agit plus gros ours ex ce sont deibul
d'ours BR et qui présente une
caractéristique
pathologique
assez intéressante ouais tu as le pouce
dedans ouais c'est ou ouais je en de
réléir si c pas pour une artère un truc
mais c'est totalement pathologique en
fait quand tu
regardes c'est même c'est totalement
symétrique en fait et c'est
caractéristique du passage d'un
lien autour des molires de l'ours en
tout cas et donc quand l'ours était bébé
quand il était ourson et on voit que la
mchoire et les dents ont poussé autour
de ce lien et donc c'est un des plus
vieil exemples d'ours d'ours captif il a
été daté entre 6400 et 5008 avant notre
donc on est bien à la toute fin du
mésolitique donc c'est encore l'œuvre
des des chasseurs cuilleurs c'est quel
peut être l'intérêt de garder un un
jeune pendant plusieurs années sachant
que si on est parmi des populations qui
bougent il faut se le trimbaler aussiin
c'estf si est sur lesulou sauf si on est
effectivement sur un site occupé à
l'année et l'ours reste là et tout à
fait c'est pas une espèce qui se
domestique c'est pas c'est pas un bœuf
c'est pas un mouton c'est pas un cochon
c'est ça c'est un animal sauvage comme
le Ren ou le reste ça c'est pas des
animaux qui vont se domestiquer qu'on va
arriver à ten à tenir et à contrôler
indéfiniment après voilà c'est être un
animal de de compagnie ou de garder
l'abri méchant d'un point de vue
dissuasif c'est quand même
assez c'est quand même pas mal
ouais en 20 ans et plus de fouille c'est
quoi le l'élément la structure ou quoi
qui t'a fait je sais pas peut-être
justement percevoir un peu ce ce
quotidien cette vie parfois il y a y a
des trucs que tu trouves et tu fais un
peu un tu sais un bon vertigineux parce
que cette chose là tuévoque un geste ou
une non est-ce que tu as quelque chose
en tête qui te reste là moi c'est
c'est un peu con mais pour chaque objet
manipulé don tu es sûr qu'il a été
manipulé sty un nucléus ou les objets en
industrie seuse là tu sais que le
bonhomme il l'a tenu le dernier là qu'on
a trouvé c'est super ça on a trouvé un
super biseau en peut-être en bois de ser
ou en bois de chevreil on sait pas trop
le spécialiste nous le dira et là c'est
des outils récents mais ça m'est arrivé
avec des trucs du palé au moyen où là on
a d'autres humanités ça c'est encore
plus fort vraiment comme un bifas ou
même un bon un morceau de quartzit
vaguement aménagé tu dis punaise le
machin il a 450000
an il a servi à quelqu'un ça voilà ça
c'est le genre de truc qui qui qui qui
qui me plaît ouis et tout ce qui nous
sépare en fait vraiment un truc de fou
où tu peux pas comprendre et là tu te
dis je comprendrai jamais ces gens
souvent on on attend ça il faut
qualifier ces sites al c'est des Halles
de chasse des machin c'est des camp
temporair c'est des
BIV le début des niveaux mésolitiques ce
sont des niveaux extrêmement
sendreux tout est complètement cramé on
l'impression que c'était des gigantesque
feu donc moi j'imagine
bien vraiment ici en tout cas au cœur de
l'abri une air d'activité en tout cas
protéger de manière naturelle ouais mais
pas une zone d'habit enfin tout à brûle
tout tous les blocs sont complètement
fissurés c'est assez étonnant
et d'immenses feux d'immenses feux
peut-être de feuillus des des feux un
peu euh peu contenu c'est-à-dire des
combustions un peu lentes qui permet de
produire beaucoup de fumée et moi je
vois pas je vois du boucanage par
exemple c'est du boucanage c'est du
séchage de viande ben moi j'imagine bien
des je sais pas des des des pièces de
viande pendues là sous sous l'abri puis
avec de la fumée mais on fait du
boucanage puis on vient conserver la
viande pour une utilisation ultérieure
et peut-être en amont de l'abri
peut-être là où on mangeait une zone
d'habitat en tout cas autour en en dans
dans des constructions en en matériaux
périssables qu'on a pas qu'on a plus
aujourd'hui et puis comme on est dans
des endroits qui sont pas protégés les
c'est mon hypothèse ouis qui sont pas
d'accord probablement et puis je m'en
fous surtout pour moi il y a pas de
raison qui n' pas été utilisé à l'année
et en fait beaucoup beaucoup te diront
oh mais l'hiver il fait froid ouais
alors des populations qui vivent et qui
ont vécu dans des environnements
extrêmement haride extrêmement
froid l'homme ça moi je trouve que
l'homme sa vraiment vent très bien son
environnement faut pas minimiser leur
capacité le fait de faire du boucanageah
ça per de conserver de la nourriture
pour les périodes où il y en a un peu
moins le gibier en hiver bah ça se
traque super bien l'hiver dans la neige
c'est quand même beaucoup plus facile
surtout s saigne on a souvent tendance
aujourd'hui en archéologie à vouloir
plaquer un peu notre vision moderne des
choses c'est des populations qui se
déplace mais pas forcément peut-être pas
tant que ça non plus pourquoi retourner
faire plus de 100 km dans le sud pour
aller dans le Diwa pour aller passer
l'hiver tu es bien
[Musique]
ici
dès qu'on donnait un coup de Truel
c'était 10 eau différents qui sortaient
pas toutes de la même bête pas tout pas
tous de la même espèce on voit les
ossements qui commencent à apparaître on
était pas tout à fait au bout de nos
surprises ce qui est assez passionnant
c'est la continuité de l'occupation
depuis le néolithique en fait vous avez
sans doute plusieurs logements plusieurs
habitations des cours pourquoi pas des
locaux d'artisanat où on regarde cette
magnifique vue là où on voit ce qui se
passe dans la plaine ils ont vu arriver
les armées césariennes il on vu arriver
vers saint-je juste avant ces gens-là
qui ont habité là ils ont ils ont tout
vu de cet épisode historique n recherche
actu nous amène forcément à à se
réinterroger sur ces certitudes qu'on a
acquis au début du 20e siècle les
Gaulois on les repè par des traces
fugaces par un morceau de torque cassé
par des choses comme ça qui sont des un
mobilier qui nous parle mais en bruit de
fond qu'est-ce qu'on a dit diapag de
diaph c'est ça
je c'est la partie centrale c'est ça
épip c'est les les os les extrémités tu
dis diaphy quand tu as un morceau d'un
os dont tu as ni le début ni la
fin pas vraiment tu peux pas vraiment
déterminer à partir de la c'est comme ça
ça dépend il y a des EAU où ils ont des
formes particulières tu vois le
Charlotte je sais pas ça doit faire un
truc comme ça un
os
ou ah oui carrément non mais là ça va
pas là